so true
is true
but you can cast stuff in javascript so
we could make true cast to one if we
wanted to
which means you could do true
plus true
equals two
anyone know what this is going to do
false
see what else i got off the top of my
head just for fun the array one's fun
yeah
anyone know what's going to happen here
it's true
of course
as you'd expect
in a double equals operator or sometimes
called the abstract equals operator
it'll cast the thing on the right
so if i'm
doing this it's actually false and when
something's false on the right it's
going to cast it to an integer which
means it'll cast the other side to an
integer which effectively is like saying
is one
equal to one
which is why
this guy
is equal to this guy another way to do
this would be to say
false
ah you get the idea [ __ ] it let's talk
about what we're supposed to talk about
um
so uh my name is brian i work in adobe
with christopher joseph here
and you probably know that we work on
the phonegap team but we also started
working on a new problem at adobe and
that was css
and so our answer um is top coat and the
sort of pitch tag line is it css for
building fast and clean apps and
everybody is already thinking well why
the hell are these guys doing another
css framework um
and
there's a lot of them right we've got
twitter bootstrap we've got
zurb foundation there's a new thing from
yahoo called pure which is cool
um the problem that we were running into
consistently at least in phonegap land
people will go to build an application
and they'll quickly grab twitter
bootstrap they'll throw it in there
and their app will be slow and they'll
be like oh phonegap sucks which
isn't entirely true
so
twitter bootstrap is a meg of css
there's a good chance you do not need
that much css to make your buttons
consistent on a single platform
the other problem is twitter bootstrap
changes all the time and so there's
upgrades you have to do and they change
their class names when they're doing it
and so maintenance is a huge problem
yeah so another huge issue is uh the the
patterns that are inside of bootstrap
are huge and then kind of
all-encompassing and comprehensive and
think about the context of being a
website
not an app
so these were all these problems that
we're running into and then christopher
was working on the reflow team in adobe
and they were running the same kind of
problems building desktop applications
and we thought well okay if we're
building desktop apps and we're building
native mobile apps using html css and
javascript and we're running these
problems maybe we can work together to
solve them
so another issue uh with css is the dog
pile syndrome so you'll take
you'll take your your twitter bootstrap
or your zurb foundation you'll have this
gigantic file and you'll want to start
adding stuff to it and instead of going
in and looking at what all those other
classes are you'll just start adding
stuff to it which means you get more and
more css over time
this is terrible for maintenance and
it's really hard to perform upgrades and
so you end up just getting more and more
css added at the end and not less and if
you look at a lot of tools and analyze
css now
it's really common to have like a class
that gets used once in an application
which is crazy
so we we want to fix this
first thing that we decided to do was to
focus on performance
um i don't think any other css framework
has ever been approached this way
if they have i'm sorry
but what we're doing we're not just
saying that we're focusing on
performance but we're benchmarking
everything we do so i was talking to
the brackets team and i'm like okay how
are you guys dealing with performance
and they're crazy there was a talk about
this yesterday where they were using
high-speed cameras to like see people's
type speed and all kinds of nutty stuff
and i mentioned to paul irish and he's
like oh you should just use the chrome
telemetry api and i'm like oh that's
cool what's that he's like ah well it's
not really documented but you can find
out about it so we did we dug in and
chrome telemetry api lets us
measure all kinds of performance metrics
on
on page load on layout and on frames per
second and so as we're building top coat
we have all these discrete components
we're taking them and adding a whole
bunch to a page and we're scrolling that
page up and down
what are you going for oh yeah okay
we scroll the page up and down a whole
bunch of times and we take that data and
so we know on each commit whether or not
we're making top coat faster or slower
and so by saying performance is our
first consideration this isn't just a
statement like we're you know marketing
to you but we're actually trying to be
empirical about it and know that we're
getting faster over time
this all this stuff by the way is open
source and so we're hoping at some point
once we tool this up and we get it
working well enough for ourselves that
we'll be able to share this or you'll be
able to use this for your top coat-based
application so as your app evolves over
time you'll know if you're making it
faster or slower
um
this is all the data that we're exposing
through
so yeah
each component has this
this is cool so like these are all the
various data points that you can pull
out
i love that jank is not only a word now
it's a technical term
um i actually looked it up the other day
and the person who created the word jank
is actually in the audience right over
here her name's joni rustalka
so
it's a bit of a synthetic benchmarking
though our assumption right now is that
if we're making things faster in chrome
it gets faster everywhere else which is
not probably a really true statement
and once the other browsers give us the
ability to instrument them and get this
kind of data out of them we're totally
going to approach those too
right now chrome's our best bet and i
think it's pretty safe to say if it gets
slower in chrome it's going to be slower
elsewhere
this is a preview of a top coat based
application
this app was built for adobe max for ios
and android both handset and tablet form
factors in four weeks which is amazing
it performs really great you can check
it out for yourself
that gives you an idea what it looks
like
so
christopher did a lot of the development
and we have a lot of sort of different
design goals that are not necessarily
complementary or competing
they're just things that are important
to us that i don't think have been
important to traditional css frameworks
so the first thing that's important to
us that we want to be able to compose
our builds and christopher is going to
give a demo of this in a minute but
the idea here is that we're separating
the reset from the layout from the
aesthetic from the platform that it's
running on and so if you're on ios you
don't get a bunch of gecko prefixes but
when you go over to firefox os you'll
get all the right mozilla prefixes
you might not want all the aesthetics
turned on or off so maybe you just want
the reset so you can compose builds of
all these controls with just those
things
as a kind of
consequence of having an architecture
that has discrete builds and performance
as a first characteristic we wanted to
make this thing super modular for our
own purposes too so
making these things separate
boils right down to how we manage
ourselves in github so if you jump into
github
topcode
this does look a little crazy but all of
the controls are in individual git repos
but this wins us a huge benefit that
that means that when you're developing
using top coat and we update the button
for a bug only button updates and you
don't have to upgrade your entire top
coat installation right now when you're
working with something like twitter
bootstrap reserve foundation it's an all
or nothing proposition you have to
change a lot of files these builds
aren't discrete and they're not
independently version when they update
button they have to rev this entire css
file which is
not ideal
um
extensibility is another thing so i
showed you the benchmark server which
i'm really excited about
we talked to a whole bunch of javascript
and css developers about how they're
building applications and
they basically especially pros like dave
shea said i'm not going to use this [ __ ]
i'm a craftsman we're like oh okay well
that's cool and then he saw our
benchmarking stuff and he's like but i
want that and so we think the more
important output of topcoat isn't
actually the css that you can use
although that's a cool thing it's
probably
the tools we're using to build topcoat
itself
so we're hoping that this is kind of a
something that will encourage people to
start building applications that are
performant by default instead of uh
hucking a huge one meg css file at us
and telling us we're slow
another angle is it and this is funny
because i'm at js conf but top code is
only css
but ironically almost all of top code is
written using javascript
node so
we didn't want any client dependency i
personally have hated that about other
css frameworks that they're like oh
we're a framework but you also have to
load a whole bunch of jquery plug-ins
for some reason
um not everybody likes jquery
like me
um so
mptagens i guess
top coat's open source like everything
we do
it's apache 2 license everything's on
github we're looking for people to help
us build it
our audience is the web community but
that's everybody that's building apps
and this is also a little bit of a fuzzy
consideration it's not something i think
you should take too seriously but we're
building top coat for people building
applications and in particular
applications that are installed
things like brackets and reflow but also
phonegap and when you're building an app
there's a slight ui design idioms that
are different than if you're building a
website topcoat will work for websites
but instead of making websites the first
consideration we want to make the
interaction and design patterns
for web apps which where we think the
web is going
and
it's maybe not just the web is going
this way but operating systems are going
this way
you've got chrome os
uh
windows blue i guess they're calling it
now it was like windows rt or metro
before but it's essentially javascript
firefox os ties in and we won't talk
about webos
these are all
these are all web operating systems so
you've got google microsoft mozilla
samsung intel and i guess lg all betting
on the web is the future for operating
systems so top coats probably got a good
feature in those places and in the rest
of it we can deal with phonegap
so if you want to check out the controls
themselves we've done a really kind of
ponzi job but of of showing this stuff
off but if you go to the topcoat.io
domain we're going to do a new site very
soon you can get a preview of what the
different controls look like there's not
a lot of surprises here this is just css
and these are just like basic controls
this aesthetic is generated these aren't
things that you were telling you you
have to build it um this stuff looks
very adobe and that's probably because
it's coming out of adobe but the theming
capability allows you to change
absolutely every attribute
of uh
of these controls
um i kind of mentioned that there's some
perceived competitors i don't think they
really are
until they get into well i say this all
the time too and people think it's but
the the the principles of top code are
around performance modularity
discreteness uh and
uh accessibility
uh basically everything that these
things don't do
we do so i don't know if they are
competitors
there's a whole bunch of stuff for top
coat so it's css generally but we also
have a bunch of grunt based tooling you
get generated style guides which
christopher will show you
sample apps starter apps we have a psd
for prototyping
we also have a whole bunch of svg icons
which are pretty sweet that came out of
adobe
and two fonts which
will probably grow given the type kit
thing
so there's no js yet but that's not to
say there won't be js at some point in
the future
we're really not stoked on the idea of
creating a javascript framework but
there is some [ __ ] that the web just
does not do properly yet like touch
events that we may want to polyfill for
controls
but we don't tell you how to do
templating we don't tell you how to
build your framework we're not going to
we're not going to touch any of that
because
there's no right or wrong way
so top codes being released on the same
agile release train that phonegap and
apache cordova follows so it's a release
every month not a release every six
months
and it follows major minor patch you can
check out our backlog on github
it's actually kind of sweet we're using
this thing called hue board
which i had never heard of
but i like it
oh no the wi-fi is hosed
oh wait no it's back sweet
so if you scroll down a little bit off
top coat
you can go check out our backlog
this hue board thing is pretty sweet as
you can see
we've got a lot coming down the pipeline
and we have a lot of ideas on what we'd
like to see happens but if you want to
check that out please go ahead filing
issues is contributing
ties right into the issue
yeah
uh release train
empirical so ci driven you got that
platform support i originally was going
to put like a bunch of browsers with
their numbers on them but browsers
update every six weeks and i don't feel
like updating slides every six weeks so
whatever modern browsers you get it
there's three ways to use topcoat you
can use it the same way use bootstrap
today by including everything don't
recommend doing that for production
there's an a la carte way of building it
right now which will show you it's super
easy it uses a package json you can
choose which controls you want which
aesthetic you want and which platforms
you want to support
and as a bonus you get a style guide as
you're building it oh and theming
steaming's kind of different this is
something that's totally up for debate
we agonized about making themes
something off the
each control themselves but we're
putting themes into its own singular git
repo right now for the moment and we
don't know if this is completely correct
or not but essentially you would fork
top coat theme there's a bunch of
variable files in here some of them
are kind of gross they're not bad
to give you an idea you would give it a
theme dash whatever and it will create
that theme for
this one good example
oh yeah we're using stylus also we're
not totally locked into that but we
think it's you know better than
some of the alternatives and we wanted
to be nodey about things
yeah so you would just fork this you'd
modify the variables and you'd have your
own theme
um
current status it's uh we just did a 0.3
release we're going to do a 0.4 probably
any day now
people are building apps already using
top coat today it's only going to get
better in the future as we add more more
and more controls
there are some concerns that remain so
the first thing people have been asking
us if you go to the top code homepage
you'll see
that we're treating desktop and mobile
as separate which is making responsive
design people mad at us and
i think it's it's a valid thing to like
strive for responsive design but i also
don't think that it's something that has
been fully solved with the technology we
have today responsive design boils down
to the idea of media queries and match
media in the javascript side of things
and when you want to do it
you have a whole bunch of css and then
you can you have to download all that
css and then you basically conditionally
will decide which stuff you're going to
show when
this is really inefficient especially as
we have tons and tons of devices out
there
if you're downloading all the desktop
css to your phone
um on an edge connection just to load a
small subset of it you're hitting you're
taking a huge network penalty but you're
also taking a big penalty to the heap um
when it's trying to parcel this css so
we're treating these as separate
problems i think a lot of these controls
will eventually will become responsive
as it were and they'll be all in one
thing um but for the moment we're not
convinced and i don't think the
technology is completely there either so
we're gonna again be empirical about it
and approach it
um
discreetly
uh we're using stylus
some people like that some people don't
but you're not using stylus contributing
to top coat is a lot different than
consuming it you're consuming css that's
the abstraction layer you're at
if you don't like stylus that's cool
tell us what you do i guess and there's
complexity trade-offs in our approach we
have lots of git repos which means that
we have lots of versions of things i
think this complexity is worth the
trade-off when you start architecting a
larger application but that's that's
definitely up for debate too
um
there's definitely risks so first thing
that to address is that we're not trying
to build flex again at adobe in fact we
want to create a much larger community
around the idea of open web stuff and we
want to fix the performance
characteristics we see built in apps
today
this isn't a framework
code sizing quality is kind of the thing
that we're most concerned about so we
have to stay on top of ourselves with
that but that's what the ci
infrastructure is for and cooperation
with other javascript frameworks is also
a huge uh thing that we want to make
sure is is first class so we were
talking to the ember guys
we told the backbone guys they don't
care um
and the angular guys so there's going to
be bindings for all these javascript
frameworks so they interoperate and our
idea is that if you know whatever way
you build an app
will work with you
i bring up revenue drivers because
people ask they're like well is adobe
just going to do this thing and then
abandon it and the answer is no
there is a big internal win for us to
have reuse at adobe but there's also a
larger win when we see our tooling start
adopting this stuff and treating it as a
first-class citizen
you could imagine the benchmarking data
we're doing could become available in a
tool like brackets in the future
which is a huge opportunity
so we should be shipping 0.4 i guess in
the next day or else i'm a liar um
and
uh 0.5 coming in june and then july i
think we're going to ship one for
phonegap day
there's a ton of stuff in our roadmap uh
i won't go through all of these because
you can read i'll just highlight one of
them it's called turbo mode we think we
found a way to make css even faster
still
if you're curious about that ask me
later what what the hell is turbo mode
and
we have all the calm and sort of
community touch points github's probably
the best place to go but topcoat.io
we want to see the web be a first-class
dev platform by building apps that are
fast by default instead of ones that are
slow in order for us to do that we need
your help
and you can find out more at topcoat.io
but we're going to demo it for you now
i guess do you want to use your machine
or mine
okay
christopher's got the latest bits
and he's gonna build
an app really quickly
and then i'll pull that down from github
and i'll build it into phonegap and then
we can go get pool beers
maybe just yell at me
so i'm in the top coat i'm in the top
coat directory um
yeah
and uh
so let's show let's show you what we're
doing here so i have this package.json
file and we're actually
thinking about moving the top code part
out into its own json file let us know
what you think about that oh you didn't
mention the uh the google
mailing list we should probably yeah
we're going to start posting we're going
to be posting all these ideas and
considerations on the google mailing
list so people can tell us how dumb we
are and troll us to death
um
we've seen other people so there's like
uh component and bower
are having a cat fight over who gets to
own component json and we didn't really
want to get involved and then we're like
well everyone has a package json now
we'll just put it under a top code
global seems like a fairly okay thing to
do
because there's that file there already
we already have like license notice git
ignore
package json grunt file we didn't really
want to add another one necessarily so
well i don't know yeah i mean and also
we got burned pretty bad when we
switched from the adobe order to top.org
and bauer can unregister us so we
actually couldn't push our bits up so we
had to go with this which i actually am
pretty happy with
as brian talked about these are
corresponding these skins are
corresponding to github repos so let's
just talk about slash button if you had
your own button it'd be your username
slash button
these numbers these version numbers are
actually the tag versions of the
components in of the github repo so um
we actually have support for nightlys by
just removing the tag number and then
you can get a nightly version of
the component so if you're doing
development time you can actually see
that so this is the list of components
i'm going to build right
so i just run grunt and wi-fi should
work goes down pulls down all those
tagged versions as zips
obviously if i had a nightly it would
just do a shallower clone instead
puts it into the right place
runs a compile step um using stylus
and
i've done the same kind of stuff that um
you would want to right like i've
sequestered the brain damage of compile
into its own task so if we were to
switch to uh to like rework or something
we could just switch that one file and
everything would work the same if you
were if you really wanted to do sas like
i saw someone forked top coat removed
all the modularity and started putting
sass in as as getsubmodules it would've
been much easier just to
change the compiled tasks to use sas
instead of stylus and that's why i built
it that way
we totally want to work with these like
open package managers and stuff but we
think the space is like immature and
broken so we're just using grunt because
we're pretty sure you are too but i'm
like fully open to like trying to figure
out a better way to do this there's that
new initiative from google that used to
be called tool kitchen
polymer polymer so like i think the
features web components but i don't
think the future's here yet and so we're
just sticking to javascript and css as
the rawest form possible until such time
as the tools are better
right so this is we're using style delta
right now for our generated style guides
um give us feedback on that we actually
have another version that looks more
like our
designer generated style guides that we
could switch to but this tends to have
all the features that you could possibly
have right so the kitchen sink of style
guide features so people wanted to vote
on which ones they wanted to keep but
basically i'll show you all of the
components that i had in that
package.json already compiled with u6
example so you could just copy and paste
so you go down here you know lists
nav header nav bar and it actually has a
working button as an example and then
you know we talked about responsive and
like this header is responsive if
right but it's not made in the
responsive way it doesn't use media
queries it's actually just a
percentage-based header you could use it
that way
this is kind of a nice whoa
sorry i think like a super nice feature
because
if you saw nicole's presentation if you
don't have a living style guide then you
probably have a static one and you end
up with 50 buttons that look the same
copy paste css so our hope is that
people use this tool uh to build out
their apps they'll jump into this
generated style guide and then they will
copy and paste but they'll be copying
and pasting from something more
canonical and managed
right
um so
that's it so basically if you follow the
readme it's just you just include
whichever version of the
style guide uh no css css css theme that
you want
just you just link it like css because
it's just css and then you just copy and
paste from from here the usage species
guys and
i
i encourage people to play with these
like you know leave something out of the
list or leave something out of the
header and see what it does we're
separating things like um layout if you
look it's like
layout and positioning you know this is
i have these really dumb layout classes
like quarter half full but i'm totally
intending people to use their own grid
system and their own layout classes for
the elements and then i always want to
see what people use so that i can
actually build those things in or make
it support those things better we have
our own grid system but i don't want to
impose that on anyone so we separate all
the concerns
so i went and did a really quick and
dirty example using top coat and i just
all i did was i went in linked the css
and then copy and pasted the styles and
then
i added really minimal javascript just
for the click handler and added some
we're going to separate transitions too
so we'll have a whole set of transitions
under top coat that just use css
animations actually we're both super
interested in if you have opinions about
this one we don't really have an answer
but um is slide left a component
maybe right i'm not totally sure and
what i am sure of is when you look into
backbone apps very often you will see a
shitload of visual display logic will be
like sliding things left and right or
whatever and
i don't know if your controller should
know that right like i think your
controller should know about the state
of the models that are around like it
should know that you know i'm showing
users right now but should it know that
the users came in from the bottom i
don't know if it should
and that's kind of the nice thing about
css is very declarative and you keep
that presentation business out of your
controllers so
um talk to us about that right so we're
trying to separate concerns and the way
that we're approaching people saying so
i actually got a bug an issue request
saying hey you should have a
slide-out menu component and i said to
that i'm like well the way that we're
handling those requests is we're
actually to make examples right we're
going to make examples of composing
these different patterns and then give
you all the pieces and you can compose
your own i figured you could come up
with something way more creative than
the slide menu if you had all the pieces
and you could put them together like
legos right um
so
that's that i pushed this up to to
github again it was just quick and dirty
this morning
like trying to get this working so that
we could demo it
all right so let's see if we can phone
gap it yeah do you want to
yeah i'll swap with you
so
uh
oh yeah
that confused me
oh no i'm not that
what's up
okay cool
uh so
i downloaded a fresh
build of phonegap 2.7 2.8 should be
coming out today
steve here
is it coming out today or what
all right good enough
i'm not i'm not hating steve um
so when you download phonegap you get
a lib directory
and well
inside of there there's a bunch of
mobile platforms
um in the future we're gonna have a cli
tool that wraps all this up so you don't
have to look at these guts but you'll
always have these guts available to you
and i'm going to go
ios
bin create
we have these command line tools that
normalize all the weird [ __ ] that
different platforms do
and one of them is create and so i'm
going to create a project on my desktop
i'm going to call it
i don't know
jsconf
whoa
top coat
so that's going to generate a
native
project on my desktop
called js top coat here it is right here
this is just an ios project
and it's got a www folder so let's let's
quickly build that to make sure that i
didn't
break the world
so we have these command line tools like
cordova run which is consistent across
platforms
creating projects logging emulating
building whatever so if you're working
inside of ios
you can just switch context to android
with with
out too much trouble
so that should have worked and it did
there's an app that we built
that's exciting
so i'm going to open this directory up
and i'm just going to delete
everything except for that cordova.js
file
and
i think i pulled down your uh oh
okay
so i'm gonna jump onto my desktop
get clone
i don't remember
it's like
github slash christa
i did i did it
got your name right
okay so you already had a uh
yeah that's fine
yeah
whoa
what happened i don't know
i've never seen him do that before
what's up with that
oh the line wrapping
that's cool
that's it's all it's all of our splash
screens
it's our
overzealous designer
15 meg splash screen
um
i wish i was joking
i'm not
um
it's got a sweet gradient though
all right so where is that top coat
phone gap
just gonna copy and paste that mess
to desktop
js
cough top coat ww
replace all this stuff
cross our fingers
recompile
i did it
oh i have to kill the simulator first
i'm also running the android sdk on a
mac air so
that always works out well
let's try this again
there we go oh no
bad cash hold on
all right this is a
native dev demo gods
combo of awesome so sometimes you got to
go into xcode
and
and the running joke is that don't worry
about xcode it's just like eclipse
except it looks like itunes
i need to do like a build and clean
where the [ __ ] is that
actually this might just work
come on xcode get your [ __ ] together
it is launching
right
oh
wait
whoa i went into an ipad i guess
yay
there's our native mobile app running on
an ipad so i guess we could improve this
by doing this in a
ios context let's just quickly do this
in a
handset
so you could media query this up all you
want we're not going to tell you how to
build your app
um because
people that do suck
there we go
that was the android one yeah
we weren't even talking to you buddy
there we go it looks looks good though
right
there you go and we don't have an hour
so we're not going to show you android
so yeah top coat it's thing uh we need
your help check out topcoat.org tweet at
us
and let us know the types of stuff
you're looking for for phonegap we're
hoping to start pre-loading with lots of
example apps so that building apps cross
platforms that look good by default and
they're fast
are a thing
yeah we're into bauer and as soon as
they close a few bugs we'll totally do
that um we've we
like them and component and all these
different client-side package managers
um are
almost there they're just not quite
there
in the particular case for bower we did
publish there and then we changed repo
names and they have a bug where we can't
change repo names and so
yeah
yep
yeah it's open source now um telemetry
is a little tricky to get at today you
have to do your own comp like custom
build of cef which isn't as bad as it
sounds um but in the future the idea
would be that this tooling is fully
automated on an app per app level so
that you as a developer would get
notified that hey you just made [ __ ]
slower
when you change something
to this point
oh i should have repeated your question
the question was are we going to expose
top codes benchmarking facilities to the
public it already is it's uh top co
github slash top code slash top code
dash server
it's weird like i'm umbilical to you
so we're doing at a at a component level
right now but then we're going to work
on like you said at a um
at a page like a whole app level as well
right we're just we just haven't gotten
to that part because we've only been
working on it for a couple months
any other questions oh yeah
well so at the moment we just give you
css and oh the question is we have
desktop and we have mobile um and you
know how what are we recommending or how
do you know when to use which um we're
right now just giving you the css flat
out we're leaving it up to you to decide
how to architect your app um i'm hoping
in the future like we're going to be
doing lots of experiments around
responsive uh style designs to to see
for ourselves we're right now the state
we're at is we're actually just building
a bunch of apps
we don't want to get to enterprise
architect on this and tell people the
right way before we've actually you know
used it so
that's our that's our approach
yep
are we creating replacements for the
native
like controls
yep um those are all coming so we're
taking big lists
we actually did a ton of design research
uh around what apps are using um and
what types of controls they need and
selects and all that stuff is coming
for sure
like really soon yeah
the design research is all available
yeah actually
oh man i hope i can find it it's
it's under top
yeah it's at 404.00
it's in there
it's under the there's also some in our
wiki
yeah and actually the design research is
really interesting if you got to if you
were lucky enough to get to go to css
conf we
we had the lead uh design manager walk
through it all
that's pretty cool
uh doc
yeah doc
recommendation yesterday i was really
close
oh we're just
muttering to ourselves right now there's
been absolutely no content in the last
minute don't worry um
just trying to find where the design
research is
kind of a really awesome benefit of
being at adobe is that we have a lot of
badass xd people that really love nerdy
note on this and so they did a ton of
research into how could we create
something
that's visually clean easily styleable
and will come on come off as fast
when it gets implemented
all that research is open source too
yeah
and so we're
here
we're like you said we're redoing the
website right now to make to expose the
research documentation as well
yeah
any other questions
oh
no no other questions
oh
yes remy
okay
i'll talk a little bit about so remy's
asking what's turbo mode it's something
that we're looking at bringing in the
future um it it's an idea
extracted from famo.us um these guys
created a crazy demo where they have
this amazing sphere that's moving around
and like lightning speeds and if you
look at their source the way they did
this was by avoiding the render pipeline
in webkit and the way they do that is by
setting a style
attribute on every single element in the
dom using a physics engine to
programmatically position everything in
a 3d space using a matrix transform so
if it sounds gross
it is
but it's also super fast and so we think
we can apply this technique into top
coat to do like really crazy transitions
at like super high speeds it's only
going to work in webkit but
yeah that's what turbo mode will be
famo.us
yeah
typing on a macbook air is killing me
uh i was trying to show there's a bunch
of slides from me top coat and it's not
working i'll put those up in a way that
you can get to them but you can actually
step through
there's some slides oh my god there's
some slides that you can step through
and actually shows step by step of the
research process
all right thanks everybody
you